struggling under the weight of his
rucksack bomb
salman abedi spent two hours around
manchester arena
and adjoining train station before the
blast
trying to keep a low profile but he can
be seen on multiple cctv cameras
and his presence didn't go unnoticed by
some
neil hatfield was at the venue waiting
to pick up his daughters
at the end of the ariana grande pop
concert
he gave the inquiry a dramatic and
chilling account
of the moment he came face to face with
the bomber
sitting near the stairs to the main
foyer
i fought suicide bomber straight away
without
very little doubt in my mind it was
honestly my heart was racing
as soon as i saw him he was dressed all
in black he looked like a terrorist
it looked like he looked like a how do i
know how to explain it like a bond
villain the witness said he wanted to
call the police
but saw two security guards highlighted
in yellow and green on this image
and was convinced they had spotted a
baby and the police would arrive at any
time
he seemed frightened nervous agitated it
didn't seem right
and that that really my my heartbeat was
getting
faster and faster because i was thinking
this guy's moving into position to do
something now
but the police neil hatfield expected
never arrived
just minutes later a baby got to his
feet
and walked off to detonate his bomb
massive flashlight and i mean it was
like you know sheet lightning
it was like that filled the whole room
british transport police constable
jessica bullo
was first on scene but she admitted her
and a colleague
had taken a more than two hour long meal
break
when she returned to the arena she
missed a baby's arrival there by 10
minutes
if you had seen that man walking in that
way with that bag on his back
would you have regarded him as
suspicious if he'd walk past me
with that bag on his back i probably
would have asked him what was in it
the inquiry is due to hear from more
police and arena security staff
as a key question of whether more could
have been done
to better secure the venue is explored
in the days ahead
mark white sky news